you are watching a clip from the john
perry channel
genetics and evolution the big question
in origin of life research is how do you
get the first
replicator
and that it's still unanswered i mean we
don't
the first replicator capable of
open-ended evolution you know rna is a
thing capable of this
but rna an rna replication system is
probably not prebiotically plausible but
this is what origin of life researchers
are looking for they're looking for a
prebiotically plausible system like this
that could have emerged
on the early earth because once you have
darwinian evolution you can have
you've got information replicating
you can get functional information to
evolve and the whole game
just explodes
once you've got replication once you've
got dna going and you're you're right
that um
um
dna is definitely not a viable system on
its own
rna kind of is
but as you say it's not prebiotic
prebiotically viable
it's hard to see how you can actually
get run so there has to be something
before that
and that's okay
we haven't found it yet but um it's
something rna is a very good bridge and
our rna
is a better one than dna because rna
does function as an enzyme
dna doesn't dna needs enzymes rna
functions as its own enzyme
and so it's it's a better one but we
need something before rna to get to get
that going
and as you say is one of the unsolved
puzzles
um
it's not a totally baffling puzzle i
mean it's not sort of profoundly
difficult it will be solved probably it
hasn't been solved yet
yeah
so that was just a clip for my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below subscribe to this
channel if you enjoyed it
i upload clips pretty regularly talks
and conversations and presentations that
i've done on genetics and evolution and
i am gearing up to start doing weekly
videos again here that are completely
new completely fresh